(Voix de grand sage ) Les amis ,
est-ce qu'un  jour, un grand sage n'a pas dit :
"Il faut apprendre à rire de soi-meme
avant de rire des autres." ?
Il l'a dit
Et aujourd'hui nous allons illustrer ce propos
En commencant par prendre...
*voix naturelle* Une voix naturelle !
Vous souvenez-nous de vendredi dernier
quand on regardait des vidéos de nous-même
qui dataient de 5 ans ?
*extrait de la vidéo 5 ans plus tôt*
Il y a eu quelques malaises, hein,
quelques moments...
d'incompréhension !
Eh bah je vous ai demandés sur Twitter
de faire un Best-Of de mes malaises
et de mes BIDES  !
Parce que ouais ça arrive même aux meilleurs !
Pourquoi je perds des abonnés ?
Et quelqu'un a trouvé 10 de ces moments,
et les a mis dans une vidéo.
Et nous allons
la découvir ensemble
*inspiration*
JE SUIS PRÊT !
*Barbara Streisand*
GROS PATAPOUF
qui nous présente ça
avec la musique la plus vieille du 21ème siècle
Blague de merde alors
Ça y'en a dans toutes les vidéos hein ? Bon
*Extrait d'une ancienne vidéo de CyprienGaming*
*Silence* + *coupure*
Tout d'abord je présente mes excuses a Sebastien Loebe
Qui à cause de cette blague,
A pris la décision d’arrêter de conduire des voitures
*musique triste un peu*
Non ça va c'est une blague de merde
Mais ça c'est pas trop malaisant ça passe
Y'en a dans toutes les vidéos
J'ai des commentaires en faisant "Oh c'était nul, oh-oh gnagna!"
Et au final on adore!
Vous avez vu, j'm'imite vachement bien!
"J'ai bien apprécié la cohésion de groupe"
Dans l'donjon avec Norman qui est très important, le donjon, d'ailleurs!
Haha t'as employé le mot "cohésion de groupe" on en est là!
C'est la première fois, dans CyprienGaming
qu'il y a eu une cohésion de groupe quelque part!
Le jeu s'y prête!
*Gros vent* + *bruit d'oiseaux*
Pas mal!
Oooh!
On dit au revoir, on dit au revoir à Lucas!
Merci Desproges!
Mais on apprécie, arrêtez, arrêteez!
Ca met mal à l'aise ça?!
Nan parce que sinon je ferme ma chaîne YouTube!
Ah putain, là ça va être autre chose qu'une blague, là j'sens qu'ça va être dur!
Aaah! Aaaaah!
Ah moi ça fait trop du bien, ça fait trop du bien!
Oh non, c'était pas la réaction escomptée!
Ah nan nan! Le mec il aime les glaçons!
C'était pas la réaction qu'on voulait!
Tu aimes les glaçons dans l'dos?!
Ah ouais grave!
Ca fait trop du bien mec!
Cet homme est bizarre! Cet homme est vraiment chelou!
C'est extrêmement étrange!
Il aime les glaçons!
Quelqu'un en veut?
*...*
J'avoue, là on est sur une échelle euh...
Uuuune...
Non sur un escabeau, on est sur un escabeau là!
J'ai niqué l'ambiance en disant ça, j'l'ai pulvérisée!
Oh des fois j'devrais juste faire "Ah non ah bien joué Norman!"
Plutôt qu'de faire le mec!
Ca m'apprendra!
Ouais le quatrième était nul!
Eh les gens qui parlent on les fume, on les fume, on les fume!
Eh le CyprienGaming, faites du bruit!
Ouaiiis! Voilà j'suis tout seul!
Merci, merci mon collègue de m'avoir soutenu!
*Tête bizarre de Cyprien*
*Rire gêné*
Cyprien, je quitte CyprienGaming!
Mais non mais j'voulais pas laisser cet homme bider!
Et puis juste imaginez une seconde si j'n'avais pas crié à ce moment-là
Si j'n'avais pas sauvé Yvick finalement!
Yvick, tu dois mettre un pouce vert sur mes dix prochaines vidéos, pour la peine!
Oh qu'est-ce que j'ai fait...
"Chaud pour passer une p'tite soirée de live, tranquillement OKLM?"
P'tite anecdote!
Cet homme s'appelle Mathieu
Et on a remarqué un truc, c'est que j'lui arrive aux tétons
Donc c'est un... une belle rencontre tu vois!
Nan, j'pense que j'essayais... de meubler
mais genre encore plus que quand tu viens de déménager!
Ca vous plaît ces métaphores de merde?
*jouant un rôle* Oh! Chéri tu es là! Comment tu vas bien?
*Applaudissements + rire + cris de joie*
Eh c'était pété!
Ouais c'était sur un putain de live, on avait eu un gage
un truc comme ça, et il fallait qu'on reproduise une scène
de théâtre de merde avec Yann et qu'on se fasse
un vieux bisou!
Tout ça devant une caméra bien allumée!
Et bien en direct sur Internet!
Malaise numéro 8 : Petite humiliation
J'espère que c'est vraiment une petite!
Deux sportifs de haut niveau et Squeezie au milieu
Mais c'est tous des pointures!
Faut savoir que David Luiz lui a proposé de s'asseoir sur les genoux
"Viens mon petit!"
Allez vas-y! Allez vas-y Lucas!
Oui Daddy!
Le moment humiliant! Il le fallait!
Bonjour David!
Ouais j'me suis assis sur les genoux de David Luiz, oui!
Mais nan mais j'avoue j'suis là, avec mon tout p'tit corps
entre les deux titans que sont David Luiz et Thiago Silva, j'suis comme ça
Alors ouais, ouais, j'fermer ma gueule et j'accepte de m'asseoir sur les genoux du Papa, ouais!
Dès qu't'as fini d'parler il va y avoir un p'tit silence
Et tout le monde va être à l'écoute, et moi j'suis pas prêt à faire ça!
*Imitation nulle*
Allez à bientôt, salut!
*Guitare électrique*
Ah celui-là il fait mal!
*Frissons*
Ah celui-là il fait maaal!
J'aurais dû dire non et pour les biens du Live, pour vous, je l'ai fait!
Ah j'me souviens d'ce moment, j'osais pas dire non à Jhon Rachid
et j'voulais lui faire plaisir avec sa p'tite Karima là
mais je sais pas la faire!
Ne dites jamais oui pour faire plaisir
parce que derrière, les conséquences, ce sera pour votre gueule!
Regarde mon enfoiré de binôme qui m'aide même pas à me sortir de cette situation p*tain!
Tu vois, par contre, Yann, C'est là qu'on reconnait les vrais amis
Ceux qui font "Oooh", comme si c'était bien
alors qu'c'était de la grosse merde!
*Voix de Cartman* "Je vous emmerde et je rentre à ma maison!"
Ah il tient le Cartman!
Ah j'ai fait la surcouche quoi... Ah j'ai mis la deuxième couche!
Aaah mais j'étais une petite pile électrique à l'époque hein!
Mais t'sais pourquoi? On joue sans son!
*TENTE une imitation de JCVD*
Le son c'est quoi? C'est des ondes hein!
*A honte*
Jhon Rachid, c'est encore ta faute c'qui s'passe!
J'voulais te faire plaisir, j'voulais imiter quelqu'un qu'je sais imiter
Parce que Jhon Rachid adore imiter Jean-Claude Van Damme
et il adore quand j'limite, en train de l'imiter Jean-Claude Van Damme
Imitationception!
MAIS les réactions de mes amis n'ont pas été celles escomptées!
On a Jimmy qui pousse à jouer avec sa langue pour gérer le malaise
Cyprien, mon binôme, toujours aussi content de m'aider!
Jhon Rachid, qui rigole parce que... il a pitié de moi hein!
Hugo Tout Seul... qui est moins seul que moi, pour le coup
Et Yann qui se cache les yeux devant ce supplice!
Merci les gars, ça fait plaisir, j'ferai plus de live avec vous, c'tout
Eh bien écoutez les amis, c'était court,
faut croire qu'j'ai pas trop trop bidé ces dernières années,
mais intense!
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu, comme d'habitude!
J'trouvais ça important de clore un petit peu cette série de vidéos où on réagit à des malaises et à des bides,
en réagissant à nos propres bides et propres moments de malaises
Y en avaient deux ou trois qui étaient surpuissants, là, ceux avec Jhon Rachid
En fait, faut plus qu'je côtoie Jhon Rachid
Jhon Rachid, juste j'vais être bloqué d'partout, je n'veux plus qu'on s'voit!
J'en ai marre de toi! Dès que tu es là, je fais des bides!
A dans deux ans pour une autre compilation encore plus douloureuse, j'en suis sûr!
Allez merci d'avoir regardé, on s'retrouve très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, portez-vous bien!
Ciao tout le monde! Peace!
Sous-titres : Mina Infinity !
Abonne-toi a SQUEEZIE sinon tu vas mourrir dans 24h...=)